TEMPORARY HOLD
>> Sean: WELCOME TO HANNITY.
WE START TONIGHT A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
YOU ARE NOT DREAMING.
THIS IS NOT SOME HORRIFIC
NIGHTMARE.
AT THIS HOUR THE SCHUMER
SCHIFF SHAM SHOW BY THE WAY
TRY SAYING THAT THREE TIMES
FAST NOT ON A DELAY NATIONAL
TV.
GOING UP TO BAT.
NO NET AND I'M ON THE HIGH
WIRE.
ANYWAY, IT'S STILL GOING ON.
I HAVE A LOT OF GOOD NEWS WE
START WITH TONIGHT.
NONE OF THIS WILL MATTER
BECAUSE IN 286 DAYS, YOU,
WE, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE YOU,
I CAN REPORT TONIGHT, WILL
BE THE ULTIMATE JURY IN ALL
OF THIS.
I DON'T HAVE A CRYSTAL BALL.
I CAN'T PREDICT THE FUTURE.
I'M IRISH, ALWAYS WORRY THE
NEXT BOMB IS COMING.
THE ELECTION IS NEVER EASY
FOR A REPUBLICAN.
YOU HAVE TO THREAD THE
NEEDLE.
I'M GOING TO GO THROUGH WHY
I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS IN
A VERY GOOD POSITION.
BUT YOU HAVE THE POWER IN
286 DAYS TO SHOCK THE WORLD
AGAIN.
YOU ARE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I CAN REPORT TONIGHT THE
ULTIMATE JURY.
AND COMING UP TONIGHT WE ARE
GOING TO SHOW YOU A MAJOR
NEW POLL PUTS THE PRESIDENT
WAY AHEAD OF EVERY OPPONENT
IN ONE VERY KEY IMPORTANT
STATE.
FIRST, IN CASE YOU WERE HARD
AT WORK LIKE MOST AMERICANS
TODAY AND TAKING CARE OF
YOUR FAMILIES AND PAYING
YOUR TALKS AND OBEYING THE
LAWS.
WELL, HERE IS WHAT YOU
MISSED FROM TODAY'S
SCHUMER-SCHIFF SHAM SHOW
CHARADE.
MADE IT AGAIN.
WE LEARNED ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING NEW TODAY NOT ONE
NEW PIECE OF INFORMATION.
INSTEAD, WE GOT HOURS AND
HOURS AND HOURS, LITERALLY
OF THE COMPROMISED CORRUPT,
CONGENITAL LIAR ADAM SCHIFF.
WOW, NEVER ENDING, NONSTOP,
SAME MORAL OUTRAGE FROM
FRANKLY WATCHING HIM TODAY,
HE IS A LUNATIC.
IF YOU WATCHED HIM TODAY,
WELL, HE WAS TOTALLY
UNHINGED.
HE LOOKED LIKE A LUNATIC WHO
HAS LOST HIS MIND BABBLING,
REPEATING OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AGAIN INCOHERENTLY.
I SUSPECT THIS GUY MUST TALK
IN HIS SLEEP RUSSIA, TRUMP,
TRUMP, RUSSIA, QUID PRO QUO,
IMPEACH, IMPEACH, IMPEACH.
HE IS LIKE HAVING A
PSYCHOTIC MELTDOWN FOR THE
ENTIRE WORLD TO SEE AND
CHAMPIONS IN THE MEDIA SO
GOOD.
I'M LIKE, OKAY, THAT'S WHY
NOBODY WATCHES YOUR SHOWS.
AND WORST OF ALL, HE IS
MONOTONOUS, REPETITIVE,
BORING FOR THREE LONG
HORRIFIC HOURS.
HE WAGED THE SINGLE MOST
CROOKED, LYING DISHONEST
SMEAR CAMPAIGN THE LIKES OF
WHICH EVEN FOR WASHINGTON
TOOK MY BREATH AWAY.
HE IS A NATIONAL DISGRACE,
STAIN ON THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, A WALKING, TALKING,
LYING CON MAN, A PERFECT
REPRESENTATION OF EVERYTHING
THAT IS WRONG IN THE D.C.
SWAMP.
HERE IS JUST A SMALL SAMPLE
OF HIS NEUROSIS, PSYCHOSIS,
MENTAL BREAKDOWN TODAY.
>> THAT IS AN ATTEMPT TO USE
THE POWERS OF THE PRESIDENCY
TO CHEAT AN ELECTION FOR
PRECISE THERE REASON.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S
MISCONDUCT CANNOT BE DECIDED
AT THE BALLOT BOX.
IN OTHER WORDS, CHEAT.
>> CHEATING AN ELECTION.
THEY KNEW WHAT IT WAS LIKE
TO LIVE UNDER A DESPOT IN
2016 THEN CANDIDATE TRUMP
IMPLORD RUSSIA TO HILLARY
CLINTON OPPONENT'S EMAIL
ACCOUNTS.
RUSSIA IF YOU ARE LISTENING,
THEY WERE LISTENING.
>> RUSSIA.
>> IT'S CRAZY.
>> CRAZY.
>> Sean: CRAZY, THAT'S THE
WORD THAT
MARD THAT
MAND THAT
MAN TTHAT
MAN THEAT
MAN THE DEMOCRATS WANT YOU
TO TRUST.
EVERY TIME HE HAS OPENED HIS
MOUTH HE HAS LIED.
NOT JUST LAST NIGHT NOT JUST
TODAY.
SCHIFF GOT CAUGHT IN ANOTHER
MAJOR LIE.
ANOTHER ONE.
AS IT TURNS OUT POLITICO
REPORTING HE COMPLETELY
MISCHARACTERIZED THE SKETCHY
NEW EVIDENCE THAT DEMOCRATS
TACKED ON AFTER ON THE
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT IN
THE 29TH HOUR.
ADD TO THAT ALL THE MAJOR
LIES.
WE HAVE BEEN TELLING YOU
ABOUT THEM ALL.
WE HAVE SHOWN YOU AGAIN AND
AGAIN.
AND TOUGH ASK WHY ON EARTH,
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY DOES
TRUST THIS, WELL, PSYCHOTIC
HACK.
NOW, WE ALL KNOW ABOUT HIS
RUSSIA COLLUSION FIXATION,
HOAX, LIES.
HE WROTE A WHOLE REPORT.
DEVIN NUNES TOLD YOU THE
TRUTH.
COMPLETELY.
WE KNOW ABOUT HIS FISA ABUSE
LIE.
WE KNOW ABOUT HIM LYING
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT'S PHONE
CALL WITH ZELENSKY.
WE KNOW HE LIED ABOUT THE
FAKE SO-CALLED HEARSAY
WHISTLEBLOWER.
WE WOULD LOVE TO HEAR FROM
HIM.
WELL, HIS WHOLE TEAM WAS
COMMUNICATING WITH THE
HEARSAY WHISTLEBLOWER FROM
THE GET-GO.
AND SPEAKING OF WHICH,
BREAKING TONIGHT, PAUL
OFFICERY, WOW, BIG BLOCK
BURSTER BREAKING NEWS REAL
CLEAR INVESTIGATIONS.
HE HAS DROPPED A MAJOR
BOMBSHELL ON THE PSYCHOTIC
AND LYING CONGENITAL LIAR.
ACCORDING TO HIS DAMNING NEW
REPORT, THE DEEP STATE
WHISTLEBLOWER WAS WORKING
CLOSELY WITH SCHIFF'S
OFFICE, THAT'S WHY HE IS
COMPROMISED IN THIS CASE WAS
OVERHEARD ONLY TWO WEEKS
AFTER DONALD TRUMP WAS
INAUGURATED SCHEMING
SCIMMING WITH ANOTHER FELLOW
HOLD OVERTHOUSAND HOLD THE
DULY ELECTED PRESIDENT FROM
OFFICE.
TIME FOR ANOTHER
INVESTIGATION.
NOW, THAT WAS KLEE YEARS AGO
IN 2017.
DAYS AFTER PRESIDENT TRUMP
WAS JUST SWORN INTO OFFICE.
YOUR PRESIDENT.
YOU ELECTED HIM, WE ELECTED
HIM.
WE, THE PEOPLE.
YOU SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING
HERE?
ALL OF THIS CHARADE IS NOW
PLAYING OUT IN THE SWAMP AND
THE SEWER ON CAPITOL HILL
AND HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE PRESIDENT'S PHONE CALL
WITH UKRAINE.
THEY NEVER MENTIONED AID.
AID WAS NEVER WITHHELD OR
ANY FOREIGN ELECTION
INTERFERENCE.
THE ONLY REAL INTERFERENCE
WAS HILLARY CLINTON'S BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR DEBUNKED
RUSSIAN DIRTY DOSSIER.
"NEW YORK TIMES" EVEN SAID
OH, YEAH THAT WAS LIKELY
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION FROM
THE GET-GO.
MEDIA GOT IT ALL WRONG.
WE GOT IT RIGHT THANKFULLY
ON THIS SHOW WITH A GREAT
TEAM BEHIND THE SCENES AND
OUR ENSEMBLE CAST.
TALK ABOUT ABUSE OF POWER,
OBSTRUCTION OF CONGRESS.
NO, THIS IS NOW A CULL
ANYONE NATION.
THIS IS WHERE IT'S SERIOUS
SERIOUS -- REVENGE TO
PREVENT THE PRESIDENT'S
RE-ELECTION IN 286 DAYS.
TONIGHT IF DEMOCRATS, IF
THEY'RE REALLY CONCERNED
WITH ELECTION INTERFERENCE,
YOU NEED TO LOOK NO FURTHER
THAN IN A MIRROR BECAUSE THE
SCHUMER SCHIFF SHAM SHOW IS
JUST THEIR LATEST ATTEMPT TO
RECLAIM POWER AT ANY COST.
THEY HAVEN'T DONE ANYTHING
FOR YOU, WE THE PEOPLE.
WHAT HAVE THEY DONE?
THEY EVEN COMPLAIN WHEN WE
TAKE OUT THE NUMBER ONE
STATE SPONSOR OF TERROR WHO
HAS KILLED HUNDREDS OF
AMERICANS.
OTHER THAN THAT DONALD TRUMP
CURED CANCER THEY WOULD
IMPEACH HIM FOR THAT THE
STREAM OF NEVER ENDING
MONOTONOUS DULL, BORING,
REDUNDANT TALKING POINTS.
CAN YOU IMAGINE 24 HOURS OF
THIS SCHIFF.
COMING UP, YOU KNOW, THEY
HAD THESE PROCEDURAL VOTES.
WE COVERED IT LAST NIGHT.
WHAT WAS -- WHAT WERE THESE
VOTES ABOUT?
WE KNEW EACH SIDE WOULD HAVE
24 HOURS JUST LIKE IN THE
CLINTON CASE.
WE KNEW THERE WOULD BE 16
HOURS OF QUESTIONS JUST LIKE
IN THE CLINTON CASES.
WE KNEW AFTER THAT WAS ALL
DONE WE WOULD HAVE A VOTE ON
WITNESSES.
THEY WENT VOTE AFTER VOTE WE
NEED WITNESSES THAT WE NEVER
SUBPOENAED IN THE HOUSE WHO
HAS THE SOUL POWER TO
IMPEACH.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THAT WAS?
THAT WAS A POLITICAL PLAY AS
WELL.
THIS IS ALL AN ACT, A SHOW
THEY ARE PUTTING ON FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE IN PRIME
TIME AND THERE WAS SCHUMER
TRYING TO GET SWING STATE
SENATORS OH, JONI ERNST,
CORY GARDNER, SUSAN COLLINS,
THEY WANT TO TIE THEM INTO
VOTE SO THEY CAN TRY TO RUN
NEGATIVE ADS AND GET POWER
BACK SO THEY CAN GIVE US A
TRILLION-DOLLAR GREEN NEW
DEAL.
52 TRILLION-DOLLAR MEDICARE
FOR ALL.
ONLY TAKING IN 4 TRILLION A
YEAR.
SOMEONE GIVE THEME
CALCULATOR SO THEY CAN DO
THE MATH.
NEVER FULFILL THOSE PROMISE.
OBAMACARE SAVE 2500 PER YEAR
FAMILY WORK SNOUT THESE ARE
PROMISES UNSUSTAINABLE.
NEVER BE FULFILLED.
THIS IS ABOUT THEIR POWER.
THEY WANT POWER BACK.
THEY DON'T LIKE IT.
TRUMP, THIS IS WHAT DRAINING
THE SWAMP LOOKS LIKE.
THEY WANT NOW THE DESPERATE.
THEY WANT ALL THREE BRANCHES
OF GOVERNMENT SO THEY CAN
FINALLY PASS, YEAH, MEDICARE
FOR ALL.
THE 94 TRILLION-DOLLAR GREEN
NEW DEAL.
NO OIL AND GAS, NO
COMBUSTION ENGINE, NO COWS
OR PLANES, EVERYTHING IS
FREE THAT WILL BANKRUPT OUR
GREAT COUNTRY AND TURN OUR
COUNTRY INTO A SOCIALIST
HELL HOLE.
REMEMBER, WHEN WE HAD BIDEN,
OBAMA FOR 8 YEARS,
13 MILLION MORE AMERICANS ON
FOOD STAMPS, 8 MILLION MORE
ON POVERTY.
LOWEST LABOR PARTICIPATION
RATE SINCE THE 1970s AND
WORST RECOVERY SINCE THE
1940s, LOOK AT EVERY
RECORD THIS PRESIDENT HAS
MADE FOURTH YEAR IN OFFICE.
IDEAS ARE FAILURES,
GUARANTEED MATHEMATICALLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO FULFILL.
DEMOCRATS FOLLOWING THE AL
GREEN PLAYBOOK.
THEY ARE WEAPONIZING THE
POLITICAL SYSTEM WITH DIRT
POLITICAL TRICKS, LIES,
PROPAGANDA, MISINFORMATION.
THEY HAVE DONE NOTHING IN
THREE LONG YEARS EXCEPT HATE
THE PRESIDENT.
NOW WE HAVE HAD TO ENDURE
AND SUFFER AND WITNESS OVER
THE PAST 48 HOURS HOUSE
MANAGERS AND THEIR
DEMOCRATIC ALLIES IN THE
SENATE.
IT'S REPULSIVE.
IT'S SICKENING.
IT'S HURTING THE COUNTRY.
JUST AFTER MIDNIGHT.
WELL, PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL PAT
CIPOLLONE THEY DESERVED.
I WOULD NEVER BE ALLOWED IN
THAT ROOM.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MR. NADLER CAME UP HERE
AND MADE FALSE ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST OUR TEAM.
HE MADE FALSE ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST ALL OF YOU.
HE ACCUSED YOU OF A
COVER-UP.
THE ONLY ONE WHO SHOULD BE
EMBARRASSED, MR. NADLER IS
YOU.
FOR THE WAY YOU HAVE
ADDRESSED THIS BODY.
THIS IS THE UNITED STATES
SENATE.
YOU ARE NOT IN CHARGE HERE.
IT'S ABOUT TIME WE BRING
THIS POWER TRIP IN FOR A
LANDING.
MR. NADLER, YOU OWE AN
APOLOGY TO THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES AND HIS
FAMILY.
YOU OWE AN APOLOGY TO THE
SENATE.
BUT MOST OF ALL, YOU OWE AN
APOLOGY TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> Sean: MR. CIPOLLONE I
HAVE KNOWN YOU A LONG TIME
YOU ARE A BRILLIANT LAWYER.
YOU JAY SEKULOW.
DON'T HOLD YOUR BREATH.
EARLIER TODAY THE PRESIDENT
HAD THIS TO SAY ABOUT HIS
ATTORNEY'S POWERFUL MOMENT.
ALSO HAD A FEW CHOICE WORDS
FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
IMPEACHMENT MANAGERS.
THE PRESIDENT WAS IN DAVOS
WHERE ALL THE WORLD LEADERS
WERE SUCKING UP TO HIM, THE
ENVY OF THE FREE WORLD
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE DEFINING
GROWING ECONOMY.
AND THEY DON'T WANT THIS
PRESIDENT GOING AFTER BETTER
TRADE DEALS.
TRYING TO PLAY NICE IN THE
SANDBOX WITH YOUR PRESIDENT.
DEEP RESPECT AND BELIEF THAT
WHAT HE SAYS HE MEANS THAT
HE WILL DO.
TAKE A LOOK.
JERROLD NADLER, I HAVE KNOWN
HIM A LONG TIME.
HE IS A SLEAZE BAG,
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT PAT
CIPOLLONE IS A HIGH QUALITY
HUMAN BEING.
I WAS VERY IMPRESSED WITH
PAT.
HE HAD GREAT EMOTION
YESTERDAY.
PAT IS A BRILLIANT GUY.
BUT I HAVE NEVER SEEN THAT
EMOTION.
AND THAT'S REAL EMOTION.
THAT'S BECAUSE HE KNOWS THIS
IS A HOAX.
AND I WAS VERY PROUD OF THE
JOB HE DID.
>> Sean: I'M ASSUMING THE
PRESIDENT LIKE HAD AN HOUR
AND A HALF SLEEP AND HE GAVE
A GREAT PRESS CONFERENCE.
I WATCHED THE WHOLE THING
THIS MORNING.
I'M TOLD ADAM SCHIFF IS
AGAIN BACK DOING IT MORE.
NOW, IF I WAS A TERRIBLE
HOST, I WOULD FORCE YOU TO
ENDURE WATCHING THE
REGURGITATION, THE
REPETITION.
PUT IT UP FOR A SECOND.
THE INSANITY THAT HAS GONE
ON ALL DAY, AMERICA, 24
HOURS OF NEVER ENDING
BABBLING, REPETITIVE TALKING
POINTS OVER WHAT WAS NOTHING
AND, BY THE WAY, REMEMBER HE
SENT THE NEW EVIDENCE ABOUT
LEV PARNAS OVER TO THE
SENATE IN THE 29TH HOUR?
IN THAT LETTER HE SAID QUID
PRO QUO AND HUNTER ZERO
EXPERIENCE GOT THE
PROSECUTOR FIRED THEY DID
NOTHING WRONG.
REALLY?
OKAY.
KEEP TALKING TO YOURSELF.
NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS IN
THE COMING DAYS, ALWAYS
REMEMBER CONGRESSMAN JIM
JORDAN'S FOUR IRREFUTABLE
FACTS THAT WILL NEVER
CHANGE.
HE WILL JOIN US.
ONE WE HAVE A TRANSCRIPT OF
PHONE CONVERSATION THE
PRESIDENT RELEASED.
ACTUALLY, TWO PHONE
CONVERSATIONS, WITH HIM
AMEND PRESIDENT ZELENSKY.
AID WAS NEVER MENTIONED.
IT WAS NEVER ANY LINKAGE
BETWEEN BIDEN, U.S. AID AND
THE CALL.
NUMBER TWO, JIM JORDAN, BOTH
TRUMP AND PRESIDENT ZELENSKY
SAID THERE WAS NO PRESSURE,
ZERO PRESSURE, LINKAGE
WHATSOEVER.
THEY SAID IT NUMEROUS TIMES
INCLUDING THE FOREIGN
MINISTER OF UKRAINE.
THREE, THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
ONE, THE TIME CALL, UKRAINE
DIDN'T KNOW THE AID WAS EVEN
PAUSED.
NOW, WHILE THE PRESIDENT
DIDN'T TALK ABOUT AID, HE
DID SAY NOW I'M SURROUNDING
YOURSELF WITH A BUNCH OF BAD
PEOPLE LIKE YOUR
PREDECESSOR, THAT'S NOT
GOOD.
LOOKING OUT FOUR YOUR TAX
DOLLARS.
DO US A FAVOR.
AMERICANS, UKRAINE, OKAY?
YOU INTERFERED.
WE KNOW RUSSIA INTERFERED.
DEVIN NUNES THEY SHOULD HAVE
LISTENED TO HIM IN 2014.
IF YOUR UKRAINIAN COURT IN
POLITICO JANUARY 11TH, 2017
IS CORRECT.
THEY HAVE A CHRONOLOGY OF
ELECTION INTERFERENCE
UKRAINE WAS INVOLVED YOU
NEED TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THAT FOR THREE YEARS
DEMOCRATS SAID FOREIGN
ELECTION INTERFERENCE IS
BAD.
BY THE WAY, NUMBER FOUR, JIM
JORDAN'S HITS, THE
UKRAINIANS TOOK NO ACTION.
NOTHING TO GETTED AID
RELEASED.
WE HAVE THE LETTERS THE
INVITATION OF SLESK TO COME
TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
THE AID WAS RELEASED ON
TIME.
ACTUALLY EARLY FOR SOME OF
IT.
ONE OTHER POINT.
THERE WERE FIVE HIGH LEVEL
MEETINGS AFTER THAT CALL.
INCLUDING VICE PRESIDENT AT
NOT ONE OF THOSE MEETINGS,
DID ANYONE EVER TALK ABOUT
AID.
THE ONLY ONE FACT WITNESS
THAT WOULD BE AMBASSADOR
SONDLAND.
HE SAID YEAH, THE PRESIDENT
SAID I DON'T WANT ANYTHING,
NO QUID PRO QUO.
JUST, YOU KNOW, DON'T BE
CORRUPT.
DEMOCRATS CLAIM THEIR CASE
IS OVERWHELMING FOR
IMPEACHMENT.
NOW, IF THAT WERE TRUE, THEY
WOULDN'T NEED THE SENATE NOW
TO DO WHAT IS
CONSTITUTIONALLY THEIR JOB
WE NEED NEW EVIDENCE WE NEED
TO SUBPOENA WITNESSES WE
DIDN'T SUBPOENA WITNESSES
BECAUSE WE WERE ON A RUSH TO
GO ON CHRISTMAS VACATION AND
THID A COUPLE WEEKS SUCH A
DANGER TO THE DEMOCRATIC
REPUBLIC.
DEMOCRATS HAVE NOTHING, HAD
NOTHING, THEY ARE AT THE END
EVER THE ROAD.
AS I SAID AT THE TOP OF THE THE
SHOW, THANK GOD I AM HAPPY
ABOUT ONE THING.
AMERICAN PEOPLE, YOU WILL
RENDER THE ULTIMATE VERDICT.
NOW, YOU HAVE PEOPLE LIKE
LIBERAL JOE OVER THERE AT
THE CONSPIRACY CHANNEL
SAYING THAT, WELL, MAYBE
HANNITY LIVES IN A BUBBLE
THERE IS NO CHANCE DONALD
TRUMP CAN WIN.
IF THAT'S THE CASE, I LIVE
WITH OBAMA FOR EIGHT YEARS.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
AMERICA AT EVERY RECORD
CONTINUE I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
GUYS LIKE SOLEIMANI,
BAGHDADI AND THE ISIS
CALIPHATE WIPED OUT.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
CONTINUATION OF RECORD
NUMBERS, LOW UNEMPLOYMENT
NUMBERS.
THE BEST SINCE 196 CONTINUE
FOR OUR FELLOW AMERICANS.
EVERY DEMOGRAPHIC,
AFRICAN-AMERICANS, ASIAN
AMERICANS, HISPANIC
AMERICANS, WOMEN IN THE
WORKPLACE, YOUTH
UNEMPLOYMENT.
I WOULD LIKE THAT TO
CONTINUE.
I DON'T WANT TO GO BACK TO
THE HORRIFIC OBAMA BIDEN
YEARS.
I DON'T WANT TO BE BRIBING
MULLAHS WITH 150 BILLION IN
CASH AND OTHER CURRENCY.
ALL OF THIS IS POLITICS.
THEY WANT POWER BACK FOR,
WHAT?
TO DESTROY THE ECONOMY
AGAIN?
AND BRIBE DICTATORS AGAIN
AND MULLAHS AGAIN?
NOW, THERE IS ONE BAROMETER
THAT WE PAY ATTENTION TO IN
THIS BUSINESS AND I
THANKFULLY YOU GIVE ME THIS
CAMERA EVERY NIGHT THAT'S
RIGHT IN FRONT OF ME.
YOU GIVE ME A FIKE PHONE FOR
THREE HOURS A DAY.
THE ONLY WAY I CONTINUE TO
WORK IS IF YOU WATCH AND
LISTEN.
THERE WERE TV RATINGS FROM
LAST NIGHT'S COVERAGE.
CALLED TRIAL OF THE CENTURY.
DAY ONE MINOR INCREASES
ACROSS THE BOARD.
MINOR.
WASN'T A LOT OF INTEREST
LIKE THEY THOUGHT AS A
MATTER OF FACT, CBS ACTUALLY
ENDED THEIR IMPEACHMENT
COVERAGE EARLY TODAY.
THANK YOU FOR MAKING US
NUMBER ONE LAST NIGHT AND
THE LAST NUMBER OF YEARS.
THANK YOU.
I CAN'T DO IT WITHOUT YOU.
BUT, CBS DID IT BECAUSE THEY
WANTED THEIR REGULARLY
SCHEDULED DAYTIME SOAP
OPERAS BACK.
THEY MAKE MONEY ON THOSE.
AND MEANWHILE THE PRESIDENT
WAS DOING WHAT HE ALWAYS
DOES.
HE WAS IN EUROPE CONDUCTING
IMPORTANT BUSINESS OVER THE
LAST THREE YEARS, DEMOCRATS
IN THE MEDIA AND THE MOB,
THEY ARE STATE-RUN TV
PROPAGANDISTS.
WELL, THEY RAGED.
HE IS A BUSY MAN.
WHAT HE HAS ACCOMPLISHED IN
LESS THAN ONE TERM.
>> THE FORGOTTEN MEN AND
WOMEN OF OUR COUNTRY WILL BE
FORGOTTEN NO LONGER.
THE TIME FOR EMPTY TALK IS
OVER.
NOW ARRIVES THE HOUR OF
ACTION.
FROM THIS DAY FORWARD, A NEW
VISION WILL GOVERN OUR LAND
FROM THIS DAY FORWARD, IT'S
GOING TO BE ONLY AMERICA
FIRST.
EVERY DECISION WILL BE MADE
TO BENEFIT AMERICAN WORKERS,
AND AMERICAN FAMILIES.
AMERICA WILL START WINNING
AGAIN, WINNING LIKE NEVER
BEFORE.
I WILL FIGHT FOR YOU WITH
EVERY BREATH IN MY BODY AND
I WILL NEVER EVER LET YOU
DOWN.
DO NOT ALLOW ANYONE TO TELL
YOU THAT IT CANNOT BE DONE.
NO CHALLENGE CAN MATCH THE
HEART AND FIGHT AND SPIRIT
OF AMERICA.
WE WILL NOT FAIL.
OUR COUNTRY WILL THRIVE AND
PROSPER AGAIN.
YOUR VOICE, YOUR HOPES, AND
YOUR DREAMS WILL DEFINE OUR
AMERICAN DESTINY.
WHEN AMERICA IS UNITED,
AMERICA IS TOTALLY
UNSTOPPABLE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Sean: I SAW DAN WHO
TWEETED THAT OUT EVERYTHING
IN THERE IS TRUE.
THE DO NOTHING DEMOCRATS
HAVE DONE NOTHING.